what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro and i'm here today to
discuss
porco galliard and his version of the
jaw titan just as i discussed armin's
colossal titan in the past
this seems like the perfect time to make
this video because his titan was just
introduced in the anime
and he will have a prominent role to
play in this final season
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos and want to keep them coming
then the best he could do is warhammer
smash that like button and share this
video with any attack on titan fans that
you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next video to drop
feel free to check out our colossal and
growing attack on titan playlist where
we got videos about all the titan
shifters and their powers
all of the ackermans and their powers
the titans ranked for weak is the
strongest and much much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so let's start with
porco here porco is the younger brother
of marcel galliard marcel
actually went to paradise island with
annie reiner and bertolt
he possessed the power of the jaw titan
which was passed on to emir after her
mindless titan ate him
eventually emir would willingly go back
to marley
and allow herself to be eaten by porco
thus porco inherited his older brother's
titan power
originally he was supposed to inherit
the armored titan because reiner
was actually the weakest warrior
candidate of their generation
while marcel was known for her strength
pique for her intelligence berthold for
being a good shot
and annie for being a good fighter
reiner was only known for being loyal to
marley aka for being totally brainwashed
and believing the rhetoric that the
eldians of the island of paradise
were devils who will kill everyone on
the island marcel tells reiner that he
wasn't supposed to be the armored titan
he only ended up with that power because
marcel influenced the army's decision by
putting reiner on a pedestal
and making his brother look bad he did
it to protect his little brother's life
because
not only do titan shifters get set on
dangerous missions
but because of amir's curse they also
can't hope to live longer than 13 years
after inheriting the power after this
conversation reiner was the one attacked
by amir's mindless titan
and marcel sacrificed his life in order
to push reiner out of the way
so clearly there is a lot going on
between reiner and porco who would
inherit the jaw titan only because his
brother sacrificed his life to save the
guy
porco always fought with and made fun of
now let's move on to the jaw
titan which is defined as an assault
unit according to the army and i quote
its small
size makes it the swiftest of all its
powerful claws and jaws can crush just
about anything end quote
since marcel was seemingly the strongest
and the leader of their generation of
warrior candidates
it seems like the jaw titan is top tier
and reserved for the best candidates so
don't let its relatively small 5 meter
height fool you it is an amazing titan
power and will get into
all of the reasons why so the jaw titan
is always known for its exceptional
speed and agility it's very powerful jaw
and its very sharp claws
but it was not until we saw porco's
version of it that i truly started to
understand how amazing it really is
let's analyze the battle of fort slava
to get a sense of porco's draw titan and
its abilities
one thing that's noticeably different is
that porco's face and claw seemed to be
reinforced with hardening while emirs
did not appear to be
so we can assume that his defense and
offense are better
and he's been said to be faster too
since they only choose the most fit
soldiers to inherit titan powers in
marlei
it is probable that the strength and
fitness of the user gets transferred
over to increase the titan's powers and
abilities
during the battle of force lava porco
takes machine gun fire to the face and
it doesn't really affect him much
he gets some cracks on his armored face
but those seem to regenerate soon enough
on their own
and he seems to derive no pain from the
injuries he has no problem quickly
closing the distance between himself and
the machine gun user
and he effortlessly crushes the hideout
with one hand
again showing how strong his claws are
he goes on to wreak havoc and even
destroy railroad tracks with his
powerful jaw
the jaw titan also has an advantage when
it comes to anti-titan artillery
as we saw it can break through the armor
titan's armor
so the best way to deal with anti-titan
artillery is to avoid it
and there's no titan as swift and good
at avoiding it as the jaw titan
in fact the armored titan was hit
multiple times and the beast titan only
escaped the same fate
because reiner threw himself in the way
but the beast titan obviously wasn't
quick enough to avoid the shots
so after the first battle porco's draw
titan already seems pretty good even
compared to the other titans and it even
caught soldiers off guard who were
firing anti-titan shells at reiner and
in doing so porco saved reiner from
taking on more damage earlier on now
let's fast forward to an even more
interesting display of porco's titan's
powers
specifically we're going to turn to when
aaron interrupts willie tiber's speech
this is one of the most hyped moments in
the series because we get introduced to
the ninth and final titan the warhammer
titan
and one of the warhammer titans
abilities is that the users can use
their titan power while chilling
underground in a crystal they don't
actually have the same vulnerability
of having to be in the nape of their
titan body this is huge
aaron and the others had no idea how to
break annie out of this kind of
seemingly indestructible crystal so at
first the warhammer titan seems
unbeatable
that's something to keep in mind and
we'll come back to it but first let's
just mention how well porco's draw titan
did against aaron's titan aaron
repeatedly had to be saved by levi and
then mikasa when it looked like aaron
did get a good punch in
porco actually ended up with the
advantage he caught the fist
in his jaws and completely crushed it
hardened skin
and all he clearly had the advantage and
was on the offensive aaron and mikasa
have to remark how fast he is
and how it's totally different from when
emir had the jaw titan meaning that
porco's version is significantly faster
and also stronger however against the
combined efforts of aaron and mikasa
porco couldn't win
mikasa immobilized him and then aaron
used his jaws
as a nutcracker to destroy the warhammer
titan user's crystal
as it turns out the jaw titan isn't only
the fastest titan it combines that speed
and agility
with claws and jaws that are strong
enough to break through
this seemingly indestructible crystal to
our knowledge there's no other way to do
this
that is how strong the jaws and claws of
this titan are
and although aaron embarrasses him by
using him as a nutcracker
it seems clear that he would have lost
if levi and mikasa weren't there to save
him from porco's jaw titan
we don't have to wait too long to get
the rematch
where this time the marlene warriors
make their way to the island in this one
porco's titan comes out of the ground
beneath aaron again
catching him off guard but only manages
to get aaron's legs
so aaron can still transform into his
titan form porque is fast enough to
quickly free peak from her chains
and then porco quickly retreats without
aaron being able to follow by swinging
from building to buildings sort of like
spider-man another very useful ability
of the jaw titan
especially in forests where the branches
can be used for maximum
mobility and swiftness this time though
aaron is too op
he's got three titan powers absorbed at
this point including the very useful
warhammer titan power
that pretty much lets him form unlimited
spikes around him
making it almost impossible for any
titan to approach him effectively the
marlayan titans team up on aaron and
it's still not enough to take him out
before zeke
gets there to help aaron eventually
porco gets extremely wounded by aaron
and offers himself to falco who has now
become a mindless titan because he
ingested zeke's spinal fluid and then
transformed when zeke screamed falco's
titan eats the jaw titan
and then the power of the jaw titan gets
passed on from porco to falco
falco's version of the jotan is even
more interesting but that is it for the
purposes of this video
if you do want a video dedicated to
falco and his version of the jaw
titan all you need to do is warhammer
smash
that like button and leave a comment
below to let me know and that is it for
this video
porco galliard's jaw titan was clearly
unique it's been confirmed that porco's
draw titan was nothing like emirs
since he was quicker and stronger with
his hardened claws and jaws
he could regularly catch opponents off
guard with his speed and deliver
devastating damage with his strong claws
and jaws that could even break through
the almost indestructible titan crystals
he put up more than a good fight against
aaron's attack titan in marley and as a
result aaron needed the ackermanns to
bail him out of trouble a number of
times but by the time aaron had
inherited the warhammer titan
in addition to the attack titan and
founder titan it was no longer a close
match
all porco could hope to do would slow
him down and
eventually he bravely sacrificed himself
to pass on the titan to falco
so he could return to being a human
being albeit one with titan powers
all that being said after seeing porco's
draw titan
i strongly believe it is one of the best
titan powers of the nine
if taken individually but anyways thanks
for watching if you did enjoy this video
and want to keep the attack on titan
videos coming then the best thing to do
is warhammer
smash that like button and share this
video with any attack on titan fans that
you
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane video to drop
feel free to check out our colossal and
growing attack on time playlist where we
got videos about
all of the titan shifters and their
powers all the acronyms and their powers
the times range from weakest to
strongest and much much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend
the one acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself and the most donated
champion of the world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect liam
thompson pattay heffa ruthean
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinel baked buddhist
tungsten tarkis and denki kaminari and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazowski
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font alicia actor bonnie parks xino kami
and water the red haired raven
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber thank you all so much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeoutpro and becoming a patron today
for as long as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
legendary people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah
you can support more content that way if
you prefer whichever way you support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you